>> Hello, this is Greg Dees from the Fuqua
School of Business at Duke
University reporting from Davos 2010.
I think the most exciting development over
the next decade is going to
be the inclusion of social entrepreneurs in
solving many of the world's
social problems.
Up to this point, I think there's been a heavy
reliance on top-down
solutions -- the belief that large-scale institutions
and governments
can solve these problems with large plans.
We realize now that there's a lot of uncertainty
about what's going to
work, and about what will solve the problems,
and about the kinds of
business models and approaches we need.
Social entrepreneurs have been out there working
at the grassroots
levels developing innovative approaches to
do this.
Many of them have had tremendous success.
And I think we need to learn from what they've
accomplished and
continue to learn from what they've accomplished.
And we have many of them at Davos here this
year and we will are all
learning from them and I think we'll continue
to learn from them.
I think the exciting things are going to be
a regular part of the
conversation.
To me, that's going a take us a leap forward
and I'm excited to see
that.
Thank you.